bonsoir et bienvenue sur téléphiles
soixante dix huit pour une nouvelle
édition du journal de la rédaction nous
sommes le lundi 26 janvier voici les
principaux titres que nous allons
développer un mouvement de grève des
agents territoriaux spécialisés des
écoles maternelles a touché une bonne
partie des établissements et guyancourt
et à plaisir aujourd'hui les atsem qui
dénonce la nouvelle organisation horaire
le stock de sang ont dramatiquement
faibles une campagne pour relancer la
collecte s'organise nous faisons le
point sur notre secteur des yvelines ce
week-end se tenait la deuxième édition
du concours
égérie glam plus sélection réservé aux
femmes rondes les coulisses de ce
concours qui rassemble des femmes qui se
disent fiers de leur forme
aujourd'hui si elle lundi débuter
l'examen de la loi macro emmanuel macron
à l'assemblée nationale un projet pour
la croissance et l'activité qui
suscitait la colère des notaires ces
derniers par la voix de son président
interdépartemental à versailles avance
la suppression de 15000 emplois sur les
quarante cinq mille que compte la
profession en france soit 30% des postes
yvelinois la mobilisation sur le terrain
s'est poursuivie avec une manifestation
cet après midi de nombreux offices
étaient également fermés dans
l'actualité du jour une autre
mobilisation celle des atsem les agents
qui interviennent dans les écoles auprès
des enfants à l'appel de la cfdt ceux de
guyancourt notamment étaient appelés à
faire grève depuis ce matin des agents
qui souhaitent récupérer leurs cinq
jours de congés supprimés depuis la
rentrée
mélanie poquet et patrick jacques de
dixmude
elle travaille aux côtés des enfants ces
femmes là ne sont pas professeur mais
atsem agents territoriaux spécialisés
des écoles maternelles
depuis ce matin elles sont en grève pour
récupérer des acquis obtenus 30 ans plus
tôt on nous a octroyé donc cinq jours de
congés en plus pour pénibilité de
travail est là avec l'installation du
nouveau rythme scolaire avec le mercredi
donc déjà nous on est fatigué les
enfants aussi en nous à on nous impose
un jour en plus une demi-journée en plus
et on nous supprime séjour plongée
on n'a pas été consultée au départ donc
on nous a dit ça un petit peu par la
force des choses lors d'une réunion et
on n'avait pas tout compris qu'à ce
moment là on nous supprime et c'est à
qui un manque de consultation réfutée
par la municipalité qui a proposé le 8
janvier dernier un groupe de travail
pour réfléchir aux spécificités de leur
profession le personnel à 54 jours de
congé et que par équité sur l'ensemble
du personnel
on souhaitait que
tout le monde soit au même niveau donc
comme il ya une spécificité pour les
atsem on souhaitait donc organisé sept
ce groupe de travail qui a été déjà
fixée du mois l'organisation est prévue
avec elles pour pouvoir demain avec avec
l'ensemble du 17e pour pouvoir avoir un
petit peu discute avec elle sous quelle
forme on pouvait aussi doit organiser un
petit peu tout ça selon les chiffres de
la commune à 12 m sur les 35 que compte
la municipalité étaient en grève
aujourd'hui
le mouvement doit continuer toute la
semaine en cette période de plan
vigipirate certains veut prennent plus
d'importance que d'autres ce sont ceux
par exemple représenté par le président
de la communauté d'agglomération de 50
ans aux forces de police et de sécurité
policiers nationaux municipaux pompiers
forces de police ferroviaire était ainsi
mis à l'honneur michel lauzier michel
laugier les a vivement remercié en fin
de semaine dernière pour le travail
effectué rappelons également
l'importance d'une synergie entre police
municipale et police nationale il a
également souligné les liens forts qui
unissent cette communauté
d'agglomération cette communauté avec le
territoire un territoire qui sera amené
à s'élargir au 1er janvier 2016 et de
noter qu'un événement majeur sportif
attend les forces de sécurité ce sont
les championnats du monde 18 au 22
février prochain un autre moment fort de
mobilisation donc le don du sang
maintenant c'est urgent non du la
campagne qui vient d'être lancée qui
vient tout juste de débuter et c'est le
thème de l'entretien de ce journal
regardez ce spot tout d'abord
aujourd'hui nous réserve de sang sont
faibles en donnant votre sang vous
pouvez sauver des vies
don de sang maintenant c'est urgent pour
savoir où donner rendez vous sur
dondusang.net et pour parler du don du
sang le docteur denis pagès bonsoir et
bienvenue vous êtes le responsable du
pôle et ile de france ouest de
l'établissement français du sang une
compagne d'urgence c'est finalement
assez rare à ce point là aujourd'hui
quelle est la situation actuelle alors
pour être confortable nous avons besoin
de 12 14 jours de stocks en globules
rouges
nous sommes actuellement à neuf jours
c'est à dire que nous n'avons aucune
marge de sécurité alors j insiste nous
ne sommes pas en pénurie
nous sommes en délicatesse de stock et
ce stock il faut absolument le
renouveler pourquoi parce que bas depuis
octobre on sait qu'on commence à être
faibles là dessus et la période d'hiver
avec la grippe et gastro les infections
diverses fait que les moins de monde
peuvent donner
il ya des contre indications à la fois
pour protéger la santé du donneur est
aussi celle du receveur
donc c'est régulier toujours la même
période chaque année on a à peu près le
même problème alors là cette année c'est
particulièrement important je voudrais
rappeler qu' il ya plusieurs points
les globules rouges dans les conserves
42 jours est un autre élément important
ce sont les plaquettes et les plaquettes
et cinq jours et demi c'est à dire que
ça ne sert à rien de faire des stocks
nos stocks qui donnait à 14 jours là on
est confortable on continue gérait pas
de la routine parce que le don du sang
tout cas la collecte s'est jamais de la
routine c'est pas la même heure c'est
par les mêmes endroits on a vraiment
besoin que les gens se mobilisent et je
peux comprendre que
les trois dernières semaines qui est
dernières semaines nos pas concouru à
mobiliser les gens à donner leur sang à
l'actualité vous pensez aujourd'hui les
difficultés rencontrées si on avait un
si on avait vraiment et on en a déjà
parlé plusieurs fois si on avait la
réponse aux questions on n'aurait pas
besoin de faire cette campagne de
mobilisation c'est multifactoriel il
n'ya pas d'algorithmes qui permettent de
savoir il ya des suppositions
peut-être aussi que mais ça c'est la
base
les les citoyens ne sont pas mobilisés
ac notamment durant le temps scolaire
vous prenez les classes de svt en
troisième en est-il sens c'est parfait
mais on ne dit jamais que le sang peut
servir à soigner des gens et que c'est
aussi et bien un médicament mais toute
une éducation à faire soutient toute
affaire départ et ça dépend aussi
beaucoup et on en a pas mal an dans dans
les yvelines des professeurs de svt qui
se mobilisent qu'ils nous appellent et
avec lesquels et le soutien des enfants
même la mobilisation des enfants
on arrive à organiser des collectes
pourquoi les gens ont des difficultés à
donner leur sang c'est notre question du
jour je vous propose d'écouter ce micro
trottoir
on nous informe pas assez de commandes
donné les procédures et tout ça j'ai
remarqué qu'ils avaient beaucoup de gens
qui met pas qu'on leur fasse des prises
de sang donc c'est peut-être ça
peut-être qu'ils ont pas l'information
correcte voilà ils sont pas informés
comment ça se passe et où ça se passe le
lieu - personnellement si j'ai pas
confiance
j'ai peur que il a un style soit infecté
peut-être par manque d'informations je
pense parce qu'ils ont peur de voir du
sang moi je n'hésite pas mais j'oublie
avant quand c'était au travail
il y avait une camionnette qui venait et
puis j'y allais volontiers et puis
depuis que ça existe plus eh ben j'ai du
mal à me projeter donc d'information
quelques craintes aussi encore sur la
wii devrait pas reprendre le sketch de
madame fort estimé les gars on sème la
viande le pomme de terre et par des
piqûres
c'est drôle mais c'est vrai souvent
c'est vrai le deuxième point alors là la
sécurité du donneur m dames âgées peur
que la seringue d'abord c'est pas une
seringue c'est une aiguille alors il
faut savoir que tout le matériel utilisé
est un usage unique c'est à dire que ça
ne sert c'est stérile au moment de s'en
servir et vous forçant à servir on le
jette
voilà donc sa série j'entends rassuré
sur sa wii alors maintenant les
conditions bas il faut avoir au moins 18
ans moins de 70 ans
il faut peser plus de 50 kg et je fais
un appel
on a besoin
de tous les donneurs et notamment des
hommes pourquoi parce qu'ils sont plus
grands ils sont plus costauds et donc on
peut prélever un petit peu plus
alors c'est l'air de rien mais d milite
par six en plus dix minutes par là ça
finit par faire des volumes importants
et puis un autre point aussi c'est qu'on
a besoin du sang savez dans le sens il
ya trois produits il ya des globules
rouges et plaquettes et le plasma et le
plasma c'est important parce que ça sert
à la fois en thérapeutique pour traiter
les déshydratation les grands volets
autres et puis grâce au placement on
peut faire des médicaments qui sont
dérivés comme les anticorps anti
hépatite b et on a besoin de ces
anticorps pour ce qui est de moins en
moins de gens qui sont vaccinés contre
l'hépatite b est à plus de gens de plus
en plus qu'ils en font enfin dernier
point aussi on a besoin grosso modo si
riche de france
deux mille cinq cents dons par jour
c'est à dire que nous on a besoin d'à
peu près de 3 enfin on a on a un
objectif de 1400 dont en moyenne par
semaine sur six jours et ce qu'il faut
savoir aussi c'est qu'il est pauvre
seulement quantitatif mais aussi
qualitatif
il ya deux maladies génétiques dont
l'une la drépanocytose représentent 25%
d'un des maladies génétiques en france
c'est la première maladie génétique au
monde un nouveau né sur six mille naît
avec une vraie manne aussitôt il a des
globules rouges anormaux c'est pas de sa
faute c'est génétique et que cet enfant
dès son plus jeune âge sera dans
l'obligation de faire changer son sens
hier qu'on va prendre le sens qui est
malade et on lui fera des transfusions
et ça il faut savoir il ya la deuxième
maladie aussi qui affecte alors la
drépanocytose
il faut dire ça a fait que plutôt les
gens d'origines frontières et je lance
un appel
la communauté afro antillaise pour venir
donner l'ensemble puisque comme ces
enfants vont être transfusé pendant des
années des années plus leur âge augmente
moins on pourra les transférer
facilement
or il ya des groupes sanguins très
particulier dans la population afro
antillaises et si on peut coller le plus
possible il n'y a pas quatre groupes
sanguins et à la 37
on va prendre des dix plus importants et
autres et si on peut avoir ce sens
qualitativement meilleure on pourra
prolonger à la fois la durée et la
qualité de la vie de ses enfants
est ce que c'est important ce que vous
dites y'a pas que quatre groupes de 100
avec 4 mai à gré aux résultats qu'elle
du filet au texas et les 4 et 5 le plus
important qu'on utilise en fait des
groupes sanguins et la 35 alors ils sont
plus ou moins importants en terme de
deux générations il suscite plus ou
moins d anticorps quand le sang est
transfusé et là on essaye dans le cadre
à venir prennent aussitôt d'être le plus
proche possible des quais les besoins
spécifiques en plus de la sologne rim et
les difficultés le stock actuel il ya
ces besoins spécifiques vous les avez
entendu ce soir là les collectes qui se
déroule quelques fois un peu partout on
est toujours informé le mais est ce qui
est un moyen rapide facile de donner son
sang si on veut sans attendre une
collecte il recentre tout simplement
alors on a trois centres sur l'ouest
parisien dans les yvelines
on à versailles qui est ouvert comme
quoi si d'ailleurs six jours sur sept
et puis à rambouillet aussi mais qui est
ouvert quelques jours 3 les deux jours
par semaine une semaine sur deux qui
fait qu'il n'y ait eu ou effectivement
pour le don de sang total
on n'est pas obligé de prendre rendez
vous il est conseillé d'appeler comme ça
on vous donnera le créneau horaire où
vous serez sûr ne pas attendre vous
n'attendrez pas vous aurez
une salle des prélèvements confortable
avec un vrai fauteuil de prélèvement
voilà donc j'incite les gens et puis si
les gens s'y sentent bien
si leur groupe sanguin est intéressant
entre guillemets on leur proposera même
de donner leur plasma je pense à tous
les gens qui ont été vaccinés contre
l'hépatite b et qui ont des anticorps
très élevé à ce moment là on utilisera
leur plasma pour fabriquer des
immunoglobulines anti hépatite b et
l'adresse internet qui va s'afficher une
nouvelle fois si vous voulez tous les
renseignements une dernière question on
a déjà parlé avec vous sur ce plateau
mais forcément au moment où les stocks
sont difficiles à constituer même s'il
n'ya pas encore pénurie c'est la
population homosexuelle qui ne peut pas
donner son sang il y avait un avis qui
avait été demandé par parle par le
comité consultatif national d'éthique
voilà c'est un dossier qui date de 2012
aujourd'hui on en est où et bien non pas
de réponse à ma connaissance il est
toujours à l'étude sur le bureau de
notre ministre de tutelle madden tour m
et vous attendez quoi vous pensez que ça
pourrait débloquer la situation
c'est un petit peu difficile comme
situation d'abord parce qu'elle est
européenne et pas strictement française
deuxièmement il ya des études qui ont
été menées je crois que j'en avais déjà
parlé en australie où il y avait une
véritable coopération
entre les associations gays ont un lien
comme ça est l'équivalent du don du sang
en australie en grande-bretagne
ils ont libéré le don chez les
homosexuels hommes à condition d'avoir
aucun rapports homosexuels pendant un an
avant le don c'est quand même moins bon
cette façon de dire non tout en disant
oui à donc voila moi très honnêtement je
n'ai pas d'opinion
est ce que enfin je peux pas vous
répondre
j'ai il n'y a pas de données est a
priori dans notre tête
sauf qu'on nous demande de dire niet on
n'a pas le choix
pour l'instant vous vous tenez forcément
opposition est en tout cas à la loi
puisque ça reste la loi mais peut-être
une évolution dans les prochains mois au
regard de la situation actuelle en tout
cas vous l'avez entendu les plus gros
chose de réel prochaines années sa
ceinture alors tout cas il ya un net
besoin un besoin très fort encore
aujourd'hui 200 n'hésitez pas à aller à
donner votre sang dondusang.net pour les
informations merci je vais les acquis de
taille il se produit il risque de se
produire si cet appel est entendu
parfois des files d'attenté un petit peu
longue
je demande aux candidats au don aux
donneurs un de bien relire les contre
indications qu'on affiche à l'entrée de
la collecte pour s'épargner l'attenté
d'un ton minutes inutile et pour essayer
de fluidifier mais par contre qu'ils
acceptent aussi un petit peu d'attendre
et puis l'autre contrainte aussi c'est
que nous les poches de sang une fois
qu'on a prélevé il faut que les emmène
sur le plateau technique et donc on ne
peut pas faire dix heures de collecte de
suite en tout cas soyez patient soyez
compréhensifs ya un vrai appel qui est
menée le besoin est réel mais ensuite
bien sûr il faudra l'espère on vous le
souhaite faire faire avec le succès là
je le sous thème du succès merci
électeurs denis pagès depuis on reste
dans le domaine de la santé à présent
avec l'association des diabétiques des
yvelines qui tenait ce samedi son
assemblée générale l'occasion de dresser
un bilan
là d'une situation qui continue à
alerter trop de personnes s'ignorent
diabétiques 4x de la tow elodie moines
améliorer l'information communiquée au
mieux sur les nouveautés et surtout
accompagner voici les objectifs que
s'est fixé l'association des diabétiques
des yvelines pour cette année 2015 grâce
aux plans élan solidaire
un plan d'accompagnement qui sera mis en
place au sein de l'association
à partir de cette année grâce à des
patients qui ont été formés par la
fédération et qui vont permettre
d'accompagner quotidiennement sous forme
d'ateliers sous forme de réunions les
gens diabétiques qui aujourd'hui se pose
plusieurs questions
l'antenne yvelinoise est basée à trappes
au sein de l'eee ps comme les années
précédentes des opérations de tests de
glycémie seront régulièrement proposés
car encore trop de personnes s'ignorent
diabétiques
nous savons pertinemment que le diabète
est une maladie qui va malheureusement
s'installer s'accroître au niveau de la
population et surtout le diabète de type
2 on sait très bien que d'ici 2037 les
chiffres auront probablement doublé
pourquoi nous savons très très bien
qu'aujourd'hui la malbouffe et voilà
qu'il ya moins d'activités physiques on
mange plus en plus la publicité nous
pousse à manger encore plus y compris
les en cas et c'est une catastrophe
puisque c'est le surpoids qui entraîne
une prise de creissels de finale qui est
responsable du diabète l'hypertension et
du cholestérol ainsi que l'arthrose des
articulations mieux contrôler son
alimentation
ce samedi ils étaient 10 yens avait même
préparé une galette une formule plus
légère pour expliquer que l'on peut se
faire plaisir tout en s'alimentant
correctement c'est surtout à main régime
le plus équilibré possible qui contient
finalement une grande diversité
d'aliments avec je dirais des repas
suffisamment riche en féculents centraux
avec une nature de féculents
particulière si je puis dire puisque le
plus riche en fibres c'est mieux donc
beaucoup de fruits beaucoup de légumes
des féculents riche en fibres comme les
légumes secs les pâtes complètes etc
en france 700 mille personnes seniors
diabétiques un enjeu de santé crucial
l'association milite d'ailleurs pour la
reconnaissance de la maladie comme
grande cause nationale
nous poursuivons ce journal du 26
janvier avec l'appel de l'association
france palestine au boycott des produits
israéliens par l'enseigné carrefour les
militants évinois se sont réunis devant
une grande surface porte en elle cette
enseigne à saint quentin en yvelines il
évoque une contradiction avec l'éthique
affichées par la marque
alors que certains articles seraient
manufacturés dans des territoires
occupés
et en palestine s'est produit au vu du
droit international sont illégaux
d'ailleurs le ministère des affaires
étrangères des commandes aux entreprises
de fonctionner de cette façon là donc
c'est ce que l'association cherche à
rappeler aujourd'hui en interpellant le
directeur du magasin carrefour de
montigny et en interpellant de façon
plus générale le pdg de carrefour en
france il n'y a aucune stigmatisation de
des israéliens c'est quelque chose qui
est de la reconnaissance du droit
international et l'association travaille
pour une paix juste et durable entre
israéliens et palestiniens
environnement jeudi dernier une
quinzaine de veyrier roy s'est baladé
dans les rues de la commune pour
photographier leur maison avec une
caméra thermique une première étape pour
identifier les pertes de chaleur de leur
logement mélanie poker et william peel
pour ce reportage
les points les plus chauds donc
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce qu'on remarque
qu est ce qu on voit de l'intéressant
sur cette maison si on se promène déjà
sur la façade
on a des points chauds alors voilà au
niveau de la fenêtre en fait juste
dessous et juste au dessus quelques
secondes un simple cliché pour voir les
défauts d'isolation d'une maison la
caméra thermique analyse ce qui est
invisible à l'oeil nu
les infrarouges la meilleure période
pour faire ce type d'analysé
c'est l'hiver c'est là où les différends
sont plus importantes en pour bien voir
les déperditions faut une dans l'idée à
10 degrés de différence
donc on pourrait les faire en été il
suffit juste de les chauffer la maison
35 quand il fait 22h25 on a en armes à
10 degrés d'écart mais bon je fais la
maison à 35 ans était alors que l'hiver
ça se fait tout seul
la caméra voit le problème est derrière
il ya trois-quatre explication possible
il faut creuser la lèque prête aux
propriétaires ces caméras d'octobre à
avril
mais cette étape ne suffit pas il faut
ensuite diagnostiquer les défauts et
trouver des astuces pour diminuer ses
pertes
si on n'a pas les mains de changer une
fenêtre par exemple si on reste les
fenêtres c'est de faire tomber des
rideaux devant le
le cadre parce que c'est un endroit où
il ya un échange de chaleur qui ce fait
on peut voir des petits courants d'air
constant des foires en passant de mains
le long de la fenêtre donc des rideaux
ça restait un coup froid efficace pour
les gros travaux des solutions de
financement existent parmi elles les
aides de l'agencé nationale de
l'amélioration de l'habitat
suivant vos revenus entre 35% et 50% ce
qui représente 7000 à 10000 euros x de
financement sur le montant global est
celle conditions obtenir au minimum un
gain de 25% sur vos factures d'énergie
une étude à envisager pour que la
chaleur est bien dans nos foyers
un univers un peu différent à présent
forte et fière de leur forme une
philosophie défendue tout au long du
week-end lors du deuxième concours
égérie glam plus les coulisses de ce
rendez vous avec violaine 13 et le diwan
dernière ligne droite pour emilie après
avoir répété les chorégraphies tout
l'après midi la candidate yvelinoise
commençe sa mise en beauté par la
coiffure
pour l'instant ça va mais le stress
commence un petit peu inventé en fait
voilà force de répéter
peut-être tout ensemble voilà c'est
d'être à la coiffure finalement on dit
que voilà la rapproche et milices est
prête à défiler aux côtés de neuf autres
candidates aux formes pulpeuses leur
objectif ce soir devenir la deuxième et
jerry glam plus un concours national
dédié aux femmes qui s'habillent en
taille 44 minimum et âgés de 18 à 35 ans
elles seront jugés sur des critères bien
précis la beauté a voté la beauté de la
personne son charisme
l'afld les formes sont leurs discours le
défilé aussi où on a je dis bien la
possibilité d'être bas même si on a des
rondeurs
on peut peut même être belle et élégante
emilie a eu connaissance de ce concours
par une amie elle aussi candidate
ensemble elles ont passé la première
sélection elles étaient 15 au départ les
voilà maintenant 10 à concourir au titre
c'est un rêve de petite fille déjà enfin
moi d'être d'être une princesse d'un
soir sur une scène maquiller coiffer
avec des belles robes et puis en même
temps voilà ma maman était très
complexée depuis toute petite voix là et
donc elle a eu du mal à s'accepter et je
sais que moi j'ai vu les deux fois avec
des traitements ces dernières années
donc elle soutient beaucoup de soucis et
moi j'assume complètement mes rondeurs
donc voilà si pour lui montrer que je
m'épanouis tu verras c'est pour avoir un
maximum de soutiens emilie a placardé
des affiches de l'événement à son
travail mais aussi dans les commerces de
bois d'arcy sa ville d'origine pour
autant la victoire n'est pas le but
ultime
honnêtement quand j'y pense pas je suis
pas parti pour gagner je pense pas je
vois là je me vois pas quand gagnante
mais pas de façon le but ce père le but
c'était une bonne soirée
donc voilà de vivre une super aventure
le temps presse les premiers spectateurs
arrivent et les derniers conseils de la
présidente aussi profiter
ouvrier vous allez ça va passer très
vite
quelques minutes plus tard les défilés
commencent et c'est emilie qui fait son
entrée en tenue de ville prêté par un
grand créateur
emilie ne fait finalement pas partie des
grandes gagnantes c'est amanda habitante
de l'essonne qui remporte le titre
d'égérie glane plus 2015 elle se verra
ouvrir les portes du monde du
mannequinat pour les routes en france
allez dans un instant le 7-8 ce sport
pour un point complet sur l'actualité
sportive et les derniers résultats le
journal qui revient demain mardi 18h en
direct je vous retrouverai aussi à 18h30
pour un 7 8 politique consacré à
l'élargissement de l'agglomération de
saint quentin en yvelines les principaux
acteurs du dossier les responsables
politiques seront sur ce plateau pour
ans à débattre très bonne soirée